john von neumann is a real hero actually
of not just me but many people i think
computer science and and physics
he was an incredible intellect
he probably solved a lot of the problems
that we're working on today i just
forgot to write them down yeah um and um
i'm not sure if it's john von neumann or
johnny as i think his friends called him
but as
i think he was hungarian
a mathematician came to the us
and
basically got was involved in the
manhattan project and developing
computation
and um came up with all sorts of ideas
and i think it was one of the first
people to come come up with cellular
automata
and but really i didn't know this little
fact i think i think so and i think well
anyway if he didn't come up with it he
probably did come up with indian write
it down there was a couple of people did
at the same time and then conway
obviously took it on and then wolfram
loves cas there is his fabric of the
universe
and what i think he imagined was that he
wasn't satisfied and this may be
incorrect recollection but there's so a
lot of what i say is going to be kind of
you know
just way out of my uh your lee you're
just part of the universe
um creating its memory designing exactly
yeah rewriting history re-writing
exactly imperfectly so but what i mean
is i think he he would he liked this
idea of thinking about
um
how could a
turing machine literally build itself
without a turing machine right it's like
literally how did state machines emerge
and i think that von neumann
constructors he was wanted to conceive
of a minimal thing
autonomous
that could build itself and what would
those rules look like in the world and
that's what a von neumann kind of
constructor looked like like it's a
minimal hypothetical object that could
build itself self-replicate
and um
and i'm really fascinated by that
because i think that um although it's
probably not
exactly what happened um it's a nice
model because there's chemists if we
could go back to the origin of life and
think about what is a minimal machine
that can get structured randomly so like
with no prime mover we've no we have no
architect
and it assembles through just existence
so random stuff bumping in together and
you make this first molecule so you have
molecule a
and molecule a um interacts with another
random molecule b and they get together
and they realize by working together
they can make more of themselves
but then they realize they can mutate so
they can make a b prime so a b prime's
different to a b
and then a b prime
can then act back where a and b are
being created and slightly nudge that
causal chain
and
make a b prime
more
evolvable or learn more so that's the
closing the loop part closing the loop
part got it it feels like the mutation
part
is um
not that difficult it feels like the
difficult part is just creating a copy
of yourself a step one it seems
um
that seems like one of the greatest
inventions in the history of the
universe is the
the first molecule they figured out holy
[ __ ] i can create a copy of myself
you